right
oh
yes
is
is
that's great
i think
great
um
g3
um
okay so
this
um
so
okay
um
so
okay
um
yes
um
two minute warning for the press
briefing two minute warning for the
friend's birthday
foreign
oh
okay
hi everyone
all right i have a couple of items for
all of you at the top
um and some charts we love charts in
here uh
in today's encouraging report initial
claims for unemployment insurance fell
to their lowest level
and below 400 000 for the first time
since the pandemic hit
this is just the latest evidence that
president biden's economic strategy and
vaccination plan
are working while weekly data can be
volatile since taking office
average claims have fallen by about 50
percent which you can see
in this chart over the course of time
and by more than a hundred thousand in
last in the last month alone
and earlier this week the organization
for economic cooperation and development
the oecd is
it's commonly known one of the leading
bodies in analyzing economic growth
around the world increased their
projection for u.s economic growth this
year to 6.9 percent
due to the strength of the american
rescue plan and our pandemic response
to get americans vaccinated and lift our
economy out of the crisis
uh that we inherited in fact the uh
united states is the only major
industrialized nation to have its growth
projection through 2025 revised
upward we also learned earlier this week
that manufacturing activity in may
was near its highest level in more than
15 years
okay i also wanted to note which many of
you saw this morning that
our deputy national security advisor for
cyber and newberger
who's been here a couple of times
released an open memo
to corporate executives and business
leaders urging them to take
immediate steps to address the threat of
ransomware obviously this is in light of
the attack this week the ransomware
attack this week and the one from just a
few weeks ago
the federal government under the
leadership of president biden has been
stepping up to strengthen the nation's
defenses against cyber attacks but we
can't do it
alone business leaders have a
responsibility to strengthen their cyber
defenses to protect the american public
and our economy the most important
takeaway from the recent spate of
ransomware attacks on the united states
ireland and germany and organizations
other organizations around the world
as that companies that view ransomware
as a threat to their core business
operations
rather than a simple risk of data theft
will react and recover
more effectively so our deputy national
security advisor laid out a small
number of highly impactful steps that
private sector companies can take
to harden their cyber security we've
outlined them here and again it was in
the memo that she
put out just this morning and that's
something we will encourage continue to
encourage
uh companies to do uh finally lots of
news out there this morning
as you all know and many of you were
probably on this call uh jeff zions and
jake sullivan
announced the president's strategy for
global vaccine sharing
and their allocation plan for the first
25 million doses to be shared
globally so just a couple of highlights
from that
first having successfully secured enough
vaccine supply for americans
we're donating excess donating surplus
u.s vaccine supply and encouraging other
countries with surplus
supplies to do the same he's announced
the president has announced a u.s
commitment to sharing
a total of 80 million doses by the end
of june
uh so that's 25 million doses that will
go out uh as soon as possible very
quickly a number of those are going to
even go out as soon as today
and that is five times the number of
doses any other country is committed to
sharing and 13
of the total vaccines produced by the
united states by the end of this month
second we're working with vaccine
manufacturers to vastly increase vaccine
supply for the rest of the world
in a way that can also create jobs here
at home so that so we have all these
manufacturers who have facilities that
will enable us to continue to produce
additional supply
even beyond so that we can provide that
to the rest of the world
we will also work with our partner
nations and pharmaceutical companies and
other manufacturers to create the kind
of global vaccine production
and manufacturing capacity and
capabilities that can not only help the
world beat this pandemic
but also helps prepare the world to
respond to future threats
a couple of additional highlights one in
our approach today was rooted in a
couple of considerations
one ensuring vaccines are delivered in a
way that is efficient and equitable
and follows the latest science and
public health data two providing
vaccines for populations across
different regions and those most at risk
as well as nations experiencing
surges high burdens of disease or low
vaccination rates
and finally the president as the
president said we will not use
our vaccine supply and the doses we're
sharing with the world
to secure favors from other countries
and that's a value
from the united states so today we
announced that we're sharing at least 75
percent of these vaccines which is
approximately 19 million through kovacs
which will of the 25 million i should
say that are going out uh
through kovacs which will facilitate
equitable distribution to reach those
most at risk
so approximately 6 million for latin
america and the caribbean
7 million for south and southeast asia 5
million with the african union in africa
cdc and we're sharing 25 of these
vaccines with countries
with immediate needs and to help with
surges around the world
as uh final determinations are made
about additional supply and where it's
going
we will provide that to all of you but
wanted to convey how we'd be approaching
this and where the initial
set of supply is going uh okay i hope
everyone had a snack
alex go ahead thanks jen um with the
news that the trump
justice department sought the records of
more journalists this time from the new
york times
can you talk a bit about biden's pledge
that the practice won't continue
under his justice department can you
speak to
in particular how can the president keep
that promise
while also making good on his pledge to
uphold the independence of the justice
department
sure well let me for those of you who
didn't follow as closely with alex
referenced
although i bet many of you did this is
the third announcement by the department
of justice of attaining records of
journalists during the last year of the
trump administration so something they
are
projecting publicly that happened during
the last year of the trump
administration
they've also indicated that this is the
last as you noted alex the president has
made clear that on his watch
freedom of press will be protected he
laid out core principles
several weeks ago because this is
something that he is personally
passionate about and he has a long
record with respect to protecting
the rights of journalists and as he's
always
been empathetic about he was always
alarmed by the way
the farmer administration the trump
administration
uh abused their power in some cases
and the career uh nonpartisan civil
servants often
were doing their work um with great
professionalism and honor and we're put
in a difficult
position so i will say that um he's
always felt that it's important uh it
is as is evident by his uh his um
his uh words he shared just a few weeks
ago uh that we should always be refining
and improving
our approaches uh to how we approach
this issue on any other issue i don't
have anything to preview for you in
terms of a specific policy
moving forward uh but it's something
that he is that's kind of his principles
he will approach
this from moving forward the white house
had not spoken to the doj about this
particular issue
it was it just a suggestion to the doj i
mean how is this going to become
codified
well obviously the president spoke to it
himself publicly and
uh we're in touch with the appropriate
layers of the
white house and the department of
justice and uh but certainly this is
uh the position of the president of the
united states uh what principles he
wants to abide by as president and
he he conveyed that publicly so it
wasn't exactly in secret
and then on infrastructure president
biden tried to give republicans an
alternative to funding infrastructure he
suggested a 15
minimum tax rather than a hike in the
corporate tax rates
so can you talk a little bit about how
this informs his broader vision is this
a change to his
broader vision on infrastructure and is
he basically proposing that
no profitable corporation should be able
to avoid taxes is that
the the sort of founding principle of
that proposal well on the last one
that's absolutely a principle
i will note and i know this it was a
lengthy fact sheet at the time
but the book minimum tax which is the 15
minimum tax
was actually in the american jobs plan
as one of the pay for
components so what happened over the
last couple of days and also in the
meeting yesterday
is that the president did a thorough
review
of all of the tax reforms he's proposed
many of them on the campaign so he
talked about this on the campaign
it was in the american jobs plan as i
pay for and also is reflected in our
budget that we just put out last friday
um and he looked to see what what could
be a path forward
with his republican colleagues on this
specific negotiation
now i think it's important to step back
and remember that what the proposal's
about the american jobs plan is
a historic investment in infrastructure
modernizing our nation's nation's
infrastructure becoming more competitive
around the world he's proposed ways to
pay for it right
others have not exactly done the same in
many capacities
so this is a way for him to identify
pieces that he's long been proponent of
uh as ways where he feels it would not
violate this would not
uh this would this should be uh
completely acceptable
to a number of republicans who have said
that
uh they lea they want to leave their
bottom line is they want to leave the
2017
tax law untouched so i wouldn't say it's
a new approach by the president this is
in our budget it was on the campaign it
was in the american jobs planned
proposal he also talked of course about
the benefit of tax enforcement and how
that could be a revenue raiser
but what really should stand out at this
point to people is that opposing this
proposal would not
would mean not only opposing raising
taxes on the wealthiest americans
who've done extraordinarily well during
the ten pandemic it would mean opposing
the very enforcement
of the 2017 tax law it would mean uh
maybe having the view that uh that
nobody should pay that these 50
corporations who didn't pay taxes
shouldn't pay
any taxes at all uh and that certainly
is not the view the president has
can you clarify the president's position
on the filibuster
in what way i've said i've talked about
it
yet quite extensively yesterday i'm
happy to repeat it and
often but uh the president's view is
that
uh the he believes that there should be
a path forward uh for democrats and
republicans to work together
to get the job done on behalf of the
american public whether that is
voting rights and ensuring that more
people have access to voting rights or
whether that is
moving forward on other priority items
for him
he has talked in the past about a move
back to the talking filibuster it
shouldn't be so easy
to invoke the filibuster that is his
view but it hasn't changed beyond that
good jen following up on infrastructure
quickly the president and senator capito
had said they've aimed to reconnect
tomorrow is that going to be another
face-to-face meeting here at the white
house or is that going to be happening
virtually
uh it's a great question monica i think
it could uh i don't have a
definite format for you but it certainly
could happen they're just going to
reconnect and engage it certainly could
happen on the phone
it is the expectation from the white
house that tomorrow
republicans will offer yet another
counter proposal and that that may be
the final step in the set of
negotiations or do you anticipate this
will go through the weekend
until monday june 7th i know everybody's
excited to move
work through the weekend um look i'm not
going to prejudge
uh what senator capito will come to the
table with tomorrow i
will leave that to her to speak to and
other republicans who have been a part
of these good faith
discussions and negotiations i will note
that
this has been a just good discussion and
good ongoing discussion where we've
we're working to find areas of agreement
we also feel there are a number of paths
forward
next week the house is going to be
marking up the american jobs plan
uh congressman de fazio will be leading
that effort
there are a number of democrats and
republicans who have talked about
working together many of you reported on
to come up with a proposal where they
can all mutually agree on
so president's looking forward to
engaging with senator capito tomorrow
feels they've had good discussions good
faith discussions but we're also going
to keep
options open and keep a range of paths
open for how we move his ideas forward
and on vaccines how does
the two dose regimen factor into the 25
million doses how many of them
are johnson and johnson or should this
be viewed as something that is
potentially more for
10 to 12 million people to get
vaccinated given of course it requires
two shops
and also what is the plan for doses that
may expire this month
or soon what is the us going to do to
ensure that gets there
quickly enough to ensure they can
actually be viable sure
uh well on the second question uh we are
going to of course
look closely uh to determine that um we
get doses out as quickly as possible and
as i noted 25 million will be going out
uh as quickly as we can logistically get
those out the door
um and we are going to that's that's a
certainly a factor as we are working to
operationalize this which is kind of a
historic herculean effort to
get these doses to all of the
communities and countries that we have
committed them to
uh in terms of johnson and johnson uh
you know of the doses that will be going
out they will be
all approved doses by the fda of which
johnson and johnson is one of them
i don't have an exact breakdown between
the three but you're absolutely correct
that obviously if it's johnson and
johnson it would be one dose if it's
uh the other two approved uh modern and
pfizer doses it would require two doses
do you feel like you're close to a deal
on infrastructure
did you significantly narrow the gap i
would say over time
we feel that all parties of course we
have been and we certainly feel that
senator cappano
capito and the other republicans who
have been a part of that have been
operating in good faith
now a negotiation as you know steve from
covering a lot of these is exactly that
it's seeing how
how much each side uh can come closer to
the other
uh and the president has some priorities
including
ensuring that um we're investing and
infrastructure
of the future and there are areas that
are personally important to him
making sure we're rebuilding veterans
hospitals making sure we're
making electric vehicles a reality of
charging stations buses etc some of
these proposals have been
in our counter proposal and the original
proposal and certainly
uh part of negotiating is is coming up
in numbers has he abandoned the plan to
raise the corporate tax rate to 28
absolutely not absolutely not what the
president believes is
one that uh corporations can afford to
pay a little bit more
uh and that's a way that can we can pay
for
a range of the bold proposals that he
has put forward uh but he also
took a look at uh these proposals and
the
all the tax proposals that he has put
forward over time to find a way where
there should be
um pay fors that based on their base
based on their bottom lines
many of the republican negotiators
should be able to agree to actually
israel seems to be on the cusp of a new
prime minister
what's at stake for the united states
here does this policy change as a result
of this leadership change
uh we will leave which won't be a
surprise to you steve uh
the politics and the determination about
uh political
formation in israel up to the parties
there
israel will remain an important
strategic partner uh one where we have
a in a an abiding security relationship
and that will continue go ahead i'll
come back to you guys
so just to clarify is the president's
position
that he would be willing to do away
with this increase in the corporate tax
rate
if republicans agreed to a minimum
15 corporate tax rate well let's take a
step back
the minimum the book minimum was in
the president's american jobs plan
proposal as a proposed pay for
it was also in our budget so this is not
a new idea
this is a component of what he's
proposed for a pay for that he's lifting
up as a question
as to whether they could agree to that
because it certainly doesn't violate
anything about the 2017 taxes uh so
that's what he's putting forward as
as an idea that he's asking them uh
where their point of view is
so he's saying it could be one of the
other well no he believes that we
can should continue to look at raising
the corporate rate that is a way to pay
for a range of ideas he's got a lot of
ideas out there
a lot of bold proposals including that
aren't a part of this infrastructure
negotiation
and he continues to believe that
corporations can pay more
but the bottom line is that these
proposals he's put forward as pay fors
in the american jobs plan including
irs enforcement which is also in our
budget of course and this book minimum
tax
are ways that uh unless you think
corporations shouldn't pay any tax at
all
and we'll leave that to to others to to
speak to
uh then there should be a way to find a
path to agreement
how was that proposal received by
senator capito
i'll leave her i'll leave that to her
and others to speak to um
the president said yesterday that he's
putting vice president harris
in charge of the white house's efforts
to combat
voting restrictions around the country
what is this effort
going to look like exactly what is the
white house going to do
to push back on bills that are making
their way through state legislatures
well first i would say that the vice
president put out an extensive statement
on this
just two days ago and she has this
assignment because she asked to
lead the effort on voting rights because
it's an issue she is personally
passionate about
and she wants to spend time and effort
and energy
working on what she's conveyed the
president certainly supports and agrees
on
is that there's a federal component here
continuing to push for legislation to
move forward at a federal level
but there's also an important component
of working with grassroots organizations
leaders in states and others to see how
we can push back on laws that have been
uh that are moving toward getting
approved that make it harder to vote
on how we can uh use the power of the
vice presidency
to activate energy and engagement on
these issues
and then finally the fbi has been
investigating postmaster general louis
joy in connection with his former
business does president biden believe
that the post master general should
step down or be replaced he'll leave
he'll let he'll leave the investigation
and the process forward to the
department of justice
go ahead going back to infrastructure i
understand that the president
offered to repurpose 75 billion dollars
in
unspent covered money after there was
some concern
from the white house that doing that
would jeopardize aid to hospital rural
hospitals in the areas where it was
intended intended in the beginning what
changed in that negotiation
and then is there any more room for that
given the jobs report
and the 20 states not taking enhanced
federal unemployment any more could more
be
taken from unemployment to dedicate to
the 75
billion well first let me say that what
he's referencing or
there might be some openness to is
pre-arp
money which passed during the prior
administration there is a
tiny minimal amount left so that's
certainly not going to pay for
the majority the vast majority of these
proposals
also i would note that a lot of this
funding as we've talked about before the
vast majority of this funding is
allocated
and it is meant to go to as you noted
hospitals to firefighters to keeping law
enforcement on the job
to state and localities that uh have
suffered during the pandemic
so we've proposed alternatives to pay
for these proposals
as we've been talking about a bit in
here why wouldn't it be a better option
for companies that paid no tax to pay 15
which is still a lower tax rate than
even was in the trump tax
package why wouldn't it be a better
proposal
to uh to invest in in enforcement irs
enforcement something that's
supported by 84 percent of republicans
in the country so
there are a range of ideas out there the
president's bottom line is he's not
going to raise taxes on people making
less than 400 000 a year he's proposed a
lot of different options uh that don't
cross that red line and he's looking
forward to seeing what the other side
has to offer where did that 75 billion
come from
what pot did it come out of the pre-arp
coveted funding and then um going to
the emails of dr fauci um there was an
exchange between
um dr collins and dr chowshi referencing
um
a fox news report uh discussing
uh basically the lab leak as a um
a conspiracy collins denied you know
jumping to conclusions
and um he asserted that his mention of
conspiracies was referring to
the thought the rumor that uh the virus
was
engineered bioengineered as a weapon
is that the position of the
administration and their top health
experts that this was not engineered uh
or is that still an open question and
part of this review
well i think we've spoken to this pretty
extensively from here let me just say on
dr fauci and his emails he's also spoken
to this many many times over the last
over the course of the last few days and
we'll let him speak for himself
and he's been an undeniable asset in our
country's pandemic
response but it's obviously not that
advantageous for me to relitigate the
substance of emails from 17 months ago
we've launched based on the president's
direction
an entire internal review process
to use all of the resources across
government to get to the bottom of the
origins
and that's a 100-day process and we'll
look forward to providing more when that
or 90 days sorry when it's concluded can
you speak it out to the vanity fair
report about this state department fact
sheet that came out five days before
inauguration
um you know five days before this
president's inauguration
do you know if there was any um
crossover that how that was seen by this
administration
the conclusions that they were trying to
put out um in the
final days of the trump administration i
think i'm just going to focus on
our our own internal review that's going
to use every resource in the federal
government
uh whether that is our health experts
our medical experts our national
security team
to see what more we can unearth about
the origins which certainly we all want
to get to the bottom of go ahead yeah
back on infrastructure so just because
this one trillion in new spending and
the focus on the minimum tax instead of
corporate tax hikes
is this the president's best and final
offer to republicans
well i first of all i think it's
important to note we have a range of
means for moving the president's ideas
and proposals forward
and the president's going to to have a
conversation with senator capito
tomorrow he's very much looking forward
to that
i will tell you for clarity that what he
put forward would have been new spending
on top of a baseline of 400 billion over
five years
that amount of money that would be
expected to be invested in
infrastructure regardless of these talks
and beyond that i think in terms of the
pay force
we're open to other options the
president is just not going to raise
taxes on americans making less than 400
000
a year if the republicans want to go
back to raising the
corporate rate as a part of this
specific negotiation we are absolutely
for that
and we think that these corporations
could pay more if there are other
options great
we're not going to go down the road of
user fees or other areas that would
raise taxes on the american people
and how much of the plan does that
minimum tax cover
it's in our budget and you can you can
take a look just on the corporate tax
rate
are you confident progressive democrats
in congress would get behind
a proposal that doesn't include an
increase in the corporate tax rate well
to be clear
the president absolutely thinks that
that uh corporations can afford to pay
more
and especially including corporations
that paid zero in taxes
over the last several years that's why
it was in his proposal as a pay for
and certainly a range of members
including progressives are certainly
well aware of
what was in the president's american
jobs plan proposal as paid for
and just on behalf of cyber hacking the
white house is telling businesses to
take steps to prevent this you know
what's the message to
americans to businesses that keep seeing
these attacks happening what do you
consider enforcement would you consider
other regulations that would
try to make this you know stricter to
prevent these cyber attacks
well first i will say that um there has
been
a ransomware is a global problem as i
think we you all know
uh and and we've seen these attacks run
some attacks i should say uh we've seen
these attacks disrupt organizations
around the world from
hospitals across ireland germany and
france to pipelines as you all know in
the united states
and banks in the united kingdom these
attacks have been on the rise for years
because these criminal groups are able
to make a profit off the backs of
businesses
schools local governments and more
that's one of the reasons that we're
doing
our own review uh internally uh which
has the focus of four lines of effort
because we recognize
this is an increasing threat that it is
a threat here but it's also a threat
around the world and certainly one that
we'll be discussing on the president's
trip
in just two weeks our focus is on the
disruption of ransomware infrastructure
and actors including through close
cooperation with the private sector
part of that communication building an
international coalition
hence part of the president's trip
expanding cryptocurrency analysis to
find and pursue criminal transactions
and reviewing our own ransomware
policies that's ongoing
something that's a priority to the
president and that will be a priority on
the national security team
thank you does he view the 1 trillion in
new spending as the lowest he is willing
to go
not going to negotiate from here uh but
certainly we look forward to
uh the president having the discussion
with senator capita tomorrow and as a
reminder
um there are some other lever or some
other paths that are
currently happening we're days away from
the house marking up
the american jobs plan that's something
a lot of democrats in congress are
pretty excited about as you all know
uh and also there are as as been
evidence in much of your reporting
uh democrats and republicans who have
been working together to come up perhaps
with their own proposal so we're looking
forward to seeing that as well so we're
gonna
we're gonna keep optionality on the
table and we'll see how the conversation
goes tomorrow
okay so he could potentially be open to
going to lower than a trillion dollars
in new spending
i'm not going to to give you any new
bottom lines from here
um but i think it's important to note
that there are a range of options moving
forward and certainly
his approach and his priority is making
a historic investment infrastructure
creating millions of jobs and
seeing how we can do that as quickly as
possible you noted that the markup is
just a few days away does he see monday
as kind of the deadline for any major
breakthroughs on where these talks are
going
uh no he's going to continue to
have conversations with democrats and
republicans about what the path forward
may look like
uh and certainly it's an important pi
it's an important moment in the timeline
of course because
there will be movement then we've seen
speaker pelosi
talk about how she wants to move forward
with infrastructure in june we've seen
senator leader schumer talk about how he
wants to move forward with
infrastructure in july
those are some realities in the timeline
uh but the president is not we're not
here to set new deadlines we're going to
continue those conversations
okay just checking because the
transportation secretary did say on
sunday that they do view monday as
a deadline for any breakthroughs on
these talks so
president biden does not view monday as
a deadline i think we're going to keep
our options open to see what paths we
can move forward on and
certainly the president is not going to
accept a deal that doesn't help create
millions of jobs and make a historic
investment in our nation's
infrastructure
my last question before he goes abroad
on his trip next week should we expect
any ambassador nominations to come from
the white house
uh i don't know yet caitlin we will see
um i know that there's an interest in
that
and we hope to have more soon and i
would note that one of the processes in
the ambassadorial
nomination process is that countries
have to agree
to these selections and so sometimes
that's part of the timeline
is that holding this up not a hold up
it's just part of the process
so uh go ahead annie um in general
when so much of biden's agenda includes
long-term things
that will take a while to go through
even once they're passed infrastructure
being at the top of that list
is the white house concerned that
congress is moving
slower than a sales pace on everything
from democracy reform to a policing bill
to these endless infrastructure talks
and it will get harder
as you get closer to the midterms for
your to tackle your priorities
no that's not our view uh i would say
first the
american rescue plan passed at a
pretty rapid speed uh that's typically
faster than most pieces of legislation
as many of you know
moves through congress i mean not that
this is necessarily our model in terms
of timeline but
the affordable care act took a year to
move through congress
and so we certainly recognize that
sausage making is messy
it takes some time president has talked
about wanting to sign
a bill into law this summer and there is
certainly appetite and interest and a
commitment to moving forward on
infrastructure from speaker pelosi
as well as leader schumer i would say as
it relates to police reform
we certainly know that coming together
in order to get that across the finish
line
there needs to be agreement from the
negotiators about what the path forward
looks like
they've said they're making progress
they've been encouraged by the tone of
the discussions
that's a positive sign to us and we're
going to continue to support those
efforts as they move forward
i guess just the question is you know
how are you going to show voters who are
trying to decide if i
was an effective president beyond the
falling virus members
um that his approach was working beyond
falling virus numbers beyond getting a
global pandemic under control
well i would say and you know from
polling and from what the american
people care about and are focused on
getting the pandemic under control
ensuring that we're saving
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of lives
making sure that the majority more than
70 percent of
people in this country are vaccinated so
that they can return to their normal
lives which means
returning to their jobs kids returning
to school seeing
friends going to concerts returning to
life pre-pandemic
that is the number one two three four
five issue on everyone's mind
that has been the president's focus from
day one and and absolutely how he has
spent the majority of his time to date
one other question about israel um gantz
was here today and met with jake
sullivan
uh his plan was to ask for a billion
dollars in emergency
military aid is the u.s expected to
grant to provide those funds and if so
does it have any expectation
that we would get cooperation from the
israelis on rebuilding gaza
if we did i i haven't i knew we were
going to do a readout of that i don't
know if that's come out yet the readout
of the call convention
anything about whether or not those
requests would be granted i'm happy to
check and see if there's any update on
that it may be that we have to consider
with our requests and i'm not sure we'll
have a rapid response but
i will i will check with our team and
see if we have any update go ahead mark
thank you jim
um in terms of the uh voting
the ballot bills that are being
introduced around the country the
president spoke out pretty
strongly in tulsa about them other than
um the vice president as you said
working with grassroots groups
if you don't have the votes to stop
these laws in the state legislatures and
you don't have the votes to overturn the
filibuster so you could pass hr one or
the john lewis act
what can he do then engender a
public backlash to them well one we
don't accept that that's the case
um we're going to continue to press for
congress to move forward with
legislation on voting rights we know
it's not always a straight line
and that sometimes it takes time and
there needs to be discussion negotiation
and in states it's not just about
engaging with companies
we're all working with the private
sector working with voting rights groups
strengthening and uplifting efforts on
voting rights nationwide
so this is an across-the-board effort
that's not just focused federally it's
also focused on states it's also focused
on
local infrastructure and certainly one
of the
president's lessons from having been
done this for 50 years or more
is that you know the engagement and the
activism of the american people
is often the driver of change and so
part of this effort is certainly to
uh engage with that even though some of
these bills have already been signed
into law or
about to be well laws sometimes are
meant to be changed
i have a question about the cyber
attacks is this something that he would
talk to putin about is it something he
thinks that russia
has some responsibility for or could do
something to stop
or what how does he what is putin's
where does putin fit in
to these ransomware attacks yes we
expect it to be a topic of discussion
at the summit that is happening in just
less than two weeks
and the president's message will be that
responsible states
do not harbor ransomware criminals and
responsible countries must take decisive
action against these ransomware
networks so that will be a part of the
discussion when he sees him in less than
two weeks
one more quick one just to put
infrastructure to bed yeah i don't know
if it's to bed
others have additional questions it's
like brushing its teeth or something i
don't know
he's saying that for infrastructure it's
not he could he has so many papers it's
not
necessary to raise the corporate tax or
um in just enforcement and the book
minimum would take infrastructure
because he believed
that raising the corporate tax and
raising the tax on people who make more
than 400 thousand dollars
is still necessary to fund his other
proposals
like the american fans plan or is he
does he believe that maybe this
is not necessary at all i'm not talking
whether you're for it or not
i'm asking you if he still feels that
those hikes are necessary for his agenda
he wouldn't have proposed them and put
them in his budget if he didn't think so
i mean i think there's a math not
challenge
there's a math problem here somewhere
you know in that the president's come
down
in his proposal and what and as we're
negotiating with republicans
on an infrastructure package as you
noted mar there's a range of other ideas
that he has put forward that he wants to
get passed into law
child tax credit universal pre-k etc
he's also proposed ways to pay for it so
these are components that would help pay
for his proposals in this negotiation
but certainly raising the corporate rate
uh is something to going back to what
the rate was and
you know the early days of the george w
bush administration is certainly
something that he feels
sees as a viable pay for for many of his
bold ideas
well i think it's important to take a
step back and remember this is not about
these proposals were not stand-alone
corporate tax increases these proposals
were an american jobs plan to make
a historic investment in our nation's
infrastructure they were to
level the playing field and make
universal pre-k eligible you know kids
across the country eligible
so he's proposed a range of ways to pay
for it those pay fors can be moved
around and certainly raising the
corporate rate is a
is an area he feels is a viable good
uh positive essential option go ahead
jen in light of the recent ransomware
attack uh what is the white house
guidance to
private companies the private sector
about paying ransom
our guidance continues to be from the
fbi that companies should not pay ransom
because it incentivizes these attacks on
other companies
okay and then separately on on the uh
on a fourth stimulus check idea that is
supported by dozens of democrats in
congress i know a month ago you said
you know stimulus checks aren't free and
it's really up to congress to decide
whether to move forward on that
i'm wondering at this point uh does does
the president
i think i said the right way uh and
there are some who are proposing
making the child tax credit permanent
there are some who are proposing
additional stimulus
he's happy to hear from a reign of ideas
uh on what would be most effective and
what's most important to the economy
moving forward uh but he's also proposed
what he thinks is going to be
most effective for the long term and
just to clarify the president does
support uh
an extension of the family child tax
credit that's going to
start taking effect next month in his
american family's plan he's proposed an
extension of the child tax credit
okay yep go ahead thank you
um does the choreography of the europa
trip uh having these sit downs with
allies from nato
for putin is it is this meant to
effectively project
president biden as a messenger of the
west
not just the us when he sits down with
the russian leader
well i would first say that um his
commitment to attend the g7 and nato
predated the scheduling of the summit
just factually
as you all know but i would certainly
say thematically that what you'll see
from the president and him talk about on
this trip
is his advocacy for democracy over
autocracy
domestically here in the united states
but certainly around the world
and he's always felt that we are
stronger
when we are working with our partners
and our allies many of them are in the
g7
and in nato and certainly discussing
issues
as it relates to cyber threats the
threat of climate change
uh or problematic behavior uh from some
where we have disagreements including
russia including china
would certainly be a part of those uh
engagements would it be fair to say that
that theme if you're talking about the
democracy over autocracy
is that maybe his guiding theme
through that whole week stay tuned
okay go ahead eugene um the president
hasn't nominated a
um someone for the top anti-trust role
that the doj yet
it's the longest since before hw
question just for [ __ ] there's
a hold up there in the if so what is it
i'm not aware of any particular hold up
and certainly he wants to select and
nominate the right people for each of
these important positions
um we can check and see if there's any
update on the timeline
and um on hr 40 president biden was
obviously in tulsa there
i was also there talking to some
activists and they heard from the
president and i've heard from this white
house that
he is supportive of a committee to study
reparations which is what hr 40 would do
um but he hasn't called for congress to
pass hr-40 or talk about his support for
the bill specifically
so i'm just curious if he supports the
bill that's written that just went
through
well he supports a number of components
of the bill including the
the uh the funding and the proposal for
a study which he feels would be
the next important step forward and
something that he feels would be
absolutely
uh correct in addressing this moment in
history these moments but not hr 40 as
often
i don't i don't have more of an
assessment of the legislation but he
of course uh supports uh a study for of
reparations and feels that would be
the best next step go ahead uh thank you
jen
i i know that you don't want to
re-litigate what
uh but has anyone from your team brief
the president of what was in
those voyage emails i'm not aware of him
being briefed on the publicly reported
emails
and then um given that there were some
things that fauci
said privately they contracted i
contrasted what he said publicly
whether it was masks or whether or not
someone who had the
iris you know could have immunity or um
you know uh other questions as well i
mean does he still have
confidence in his nih directors this
change anything at all
no the president and the administration
feel that dr faushi has played
uh an incredible role in getting the
pandemic under control
uh being a voice to the public uh
throughout
the course of this pandemic and again i
would reiterate a lot of these emails
are from
17 months ago or more certainly
predating this administration but
some time ago uh in uh as we look to
history
um this morning on morning joe anthony
fought he said that one of the ways to
get transparency from the chinese
on the origins of coconut team was to
quote don't be accusatory
um does the president feel that the
initial investigation of the origin of
the virus
including that wo survey that your team
had deep concerns over
was the problem with that that it was
too accusatory
i mean is that a problem uh
that this nutrition is being accusatory
or i mean is this a situation where
you know we're just following up that's
where it leads
i think that our primary objective here
has been
working with the international community
rejoining the who working with the
international community
to unite and pressing the chinese to be
transparent
uh to provide the underlying data so
other scientists can take a look at that
data
and to participate in a constructive way
in the second round
of the next round or the next phase i
should say of the who
investigation as we noted at the time
when we announced our own
internal next step here or 90 day review
uh one of the things that was happening
in the timeline was the chinese
conveying that
uh that was not their inclination uh so
i can't assess what the impact so i can
i can tell you what our position is and
what we've been pressing for on the
international stage go ahead
um yes just about the 90 day review one
thing that's not clear is how is it that
the us intelligence officials
knew about the workforce and wuhan lab
that they knew about them getting sick
back in 2019 and then in february the
intelligence officials were saying
that they still hadn't ruled out the
possibility that the virus came from the
lab
um but the inquiry didn't happen until
late may and this month
and i'm wondering what took the us so
long before it launched that's not
actually an accurate depiction of the
timeline
the president actually asked his
intelligence community uh to look into
uh to do an internal assessment which
then was presented to him an internal
meeting
back in march the uh the 90-day inquiry
that when you're describing like the
full
look at this hypothesis that was not
announced publicly and people were not
aware of until
may 2016. he didn't decide to launch it
the
the timeline here was uh he asked the
intelligence team to
do an internal review an internal
assessment when that was done several
weeks ago he asked it to be made
public to declassify that information
that goes through a process sometimes
takes a couple of weeks to do
when that assessment was done we were
presented with an option for a public
statement
and the president decided we wanted to
do a more extensive review
and tap into our lab scientists and
experts
are more of our national security team
to see what more we can uncover over the
course of 90 days that's the timeline
yeah maybe i wasn't saying it or maybe
i've seen it too specific with the dates
but the question
the bigger question is what took the us
so long to take it seriously
when there were reports about the
possibility of this virus coming from
there
you know we would completely refute that
argument or notion
obviously the president asked his
intelligence team to do an internal
assessment
which happens all the time we rarely
talk about that publicly
we obviously took the step to declassify
that and that's something that he did
early on in his administration
uh go ahead go ahead oh great okay sorry
nancy i didn't need to skip you right
go ahead are slowing
down and with the national month of
action if you do not get to that
70 percent goal what is your plan b and
is there concern that you have to throw
in some more incentives in there
uh well first we're not going to
pre-judge our outcome here on july 4th
that's
why we launched the month of action and
one of the reasons why we are working
with
uh every entity that can play a
constructive role here
free beer that seems to be very
appealing to the public
it seems by headlines uh krispy kreme
donuts
getting into raffles for flights and a
range of incentives that states are
implementing many of them did not come
from us obviously
because we recognized that at this stage
and we always knew that the rate of
vaccination would slow down
because we were at a period of time we
went through a period of time where
there wasn't enough supply for the
demand and then we got to a period of
time where we had
more supply than the demand and that's
why we launched a three billion dollar
effort to do
uh local engagement working with
community leader leaders clergy other
trusted voices doctors pediatricians
but now we're at a one month uh it
reminds me a little bit of
political campaigns where you are
knocking on doors you're making phone
calls you're
incentivizing all legal of course um
ways
to get people to the polls this is how
can we get more shots in arms and
we're we've welcomed the engagement from
a range of uh
range of entities in the private sector
to do exactly that i will also say as if
yesterday about a dozen states had met
their 7
70 or higher and ultimately this is
going to be up to individuals to get
shots in their arms
we can take every creative step we
possibly can take
we also understand we don't have a
hundred percent control here but we're
going to do everything we can from the
federal government
to reach that goal create this
initiative with shots in the shops
um within barber shops across the
country
how are you going to work with other uh
you know i guess communities especially
in the south where there is a concern
that those vaccination groups
are going down well you're absolutely
right that we are
then and they're going down in different
parts of the country which again we
anticipated
but in communities in areas where we've
seen uh the the lower numbers are
actually primarily under 40
um and they're more among young people
um and so
one of the ways we've focused is on how
we can reach and engage
with uh the communities that don't have
the highest percentage rate people over
65 there's a huge percentage of people
who have
received their first and even second
doses and even over 40 it's quite a high
percentage
so again what we've learned from our
data is that
local engagement working with trusted
voices maybe it's the primary care
physician that somebody's been seeing
for
20 years maybe it's local churches
where they go every sunday or they go
more than once a week we're working at a
very local level to do this and also
working through the private sector on uh
kind of some of these engagements where
uh it could incentivize some of the
communities that have not
um that don't have the uh as high of a
percentage rate
does the president have an idea of when
things will be quote unquote back to
normal especially
with these ramping up a vaccine efforts
well
you know we obviously are guided by cdc
guidance um but what we've seen
and they've announced over the last
several weeks is that you know if you're
vaccinated
uh you don't have to wear a mask inside
outside you know
going into stores we've seen that in
around the country as well so
we're already seeing a move toward back
to normal
but it really depends on community
community and that's the other guidance
that
we have been providing and emphasizing
because if a community has a vaccination
rate of
80 percent they are clearly in a
different place than a community that
has a vaccination rate of 55 percent
so it's really going to be
determinations made at a very local
level about what is safe
uh go ahead nancy uh just in terms of
back to the corporate tax rate for a
second
if it's something that the president is
willing to um
you know drop out of a potential
bipartisan infrastructure deal
does the white house see it fitting in
as a paper for the american families
plan or
where else could that be slotted we have
no shortage of ideas around here nancy
uh i will note that again he's put
forward a range of ways to pay for his
big bold ideas
um he including raising the corporate
tax rate
and there are a number of components of
his ideas that are not in this
infrastructure negotiation right now and
you've referenced many of them in the
american families plan
i'm not going to predetermine what all
the aligning of items will be
in the future because that obviously
isn't a package that's a part of this
specific negotiation but certainly he
thinks that raising the corporate rate
ensuring uh asking corporations who have
many of whom have made a big profit
during the pandemic to pay a little bit
more
is a is a very viable uh way to pay for
ideas moving forward
and just one more thing on the um kovid
uh vaccination district
sheridan um how does the white house
expect to donate 80 million doses
without
astrazeneca does that mean that the j
and j shot will definitely be
part of the distribution well j j has
been approved by the fda so it would be
a part those doses would be a part of
what we're distributing
along with moderna and pfizer including
in this initial set of 25 million
astrazeneca as you know we're waiting
for uh fda
approval to to even approve it to go
overseas
that's something that certainly we could
utilize those doses and they would be a
part of the doses of the 80 million
uh go ahead and go ahead go ahead alex
oh yeah just for weeks and weeks in
these
infrastructure negotiations and i'm
curious what is the white house they
could have to show
what do you think what progress would
you point to what would you point to to
show that you know we're closer to a
deal than when this process began
well first i would say that it may feel
foreign but the process of policy making
and negotiating
can be messy and can the sausage
making uh isn't always beautiful or
pretty uh so that's what we're in the
middle of right now
and the president has pledged to the
american people when he ran for office
that he would
work with democrats and republicans to
try to get
important initiatives forward on behalf
of the american people
this is an example of that we're having
ongoing discussions with republicans
we feel that those discussions have been
done in good faith
the president's looking forward to
talking to senator capito tomorrow we
also are eager to see what proposal may
be put forward by democrats and
republicans who are
talking about what they might agree on
uh so there are a range of paths forward
here and the president remains
committed to his uh goal of signing a
bill into law
historic investment infrastructure uh by
the summer
just just one more yeah the remaining
mexico policies and is it still your
message to immigrants
uh coming from central america not not
to come that the border is still closed
correct our message is still this is a
dangerous time
to come we've been clear in our
assessment that the
mpp program more commonly known as
remain in mexico was quite problematic
it led to dangerous and inhumane
conditions along mexico's northern
border in part because of the camps and
the conditions
at the camps that's something the
president talked about or we've talked
about for some time
and secretary morkus and dhs determined
that the program does not adequately or
sustainably enhance border management
either so our our message continues to
be this is not the time to come
we want to have an effective immigration
system in place
uh it's including asylum processing at
our border
and uh that has not changed but the
ending the remain in mexico
program is something we've long talked
about or come into brittany go ahead
thanks jen the president has tasked vice
president harris with too
contentious if not at least very
difficult to wrap your head around
time-consuming um issues in american
politics you know
uh immigration the northern triangle and
race through voting
rights of not just national space
council stuff that hasn't kicked off yet
uh broadband dealing with labor unions
should we expect any other major
additions to vice president harris's
portfolio in the coming months let me
say by the end of the year
well first the president's confident
that the vice president is absolutely up
to the task he sees her as a partner
and someone who uh he uh is playing the
role of a modern day vice president
which is uh which is taking on
challenging tasks uh tasks that uh won't
be easy
uh and that's certainly something he
felt he did as vice president and he
uh is uh is is confident that vice
president harris will do exactly the
same thing and
as you know she's traveling to the
northern triangle next week she's just
taken on
this initiative per her request on
voting rights
uh she's going to be active on that in
the weeks ahead so
i can't predict what's going to come our
way or what initiatives she'll need to
take on over the months ahead but uh
certainly these are two big tasks that
he's confident in her ability to lead
i know you said earlier that harris had
asked to take on this issue of voting
rights is that how she's
that portfolio's been determined has she
been the one advocating for herself
for these other assignments or has it
been typically a discussion they have
regular lunches and they discuss
areas where uh they know there needs to
be uh
one of them at the helm and certainly
this is an area where she expressed a
direct interest in
i'm gonna have to just wrap it up
shortly update on the white house cat
because that's something that's still
happening here our readers are asking us
a lot so i
bet i've been joking although maybe it
might be true that we're waiting for a
bad news day uh for that to come out
if you see a tail wagging coming out of
the briefing room you'll know
something bad's about to happen uh i
don't have any update on the cat
i know there's a lot of interest go
ahead what's the symbolic importance of
the president's meeting with
the queen at windsor castle in in the uk
and also
when he sits down with boris johnson's
obviously a long history of meeting
between american presidents and british
prime ministers but
will this one be different because the
uk is no longer part of the european
union
well we uh continue to have a special
relationship with the united kingdom and
i'm certain we'll have more to preview
early next week about what the trip
looks like but
uh there's a range of issues of mutual
interest and we've talked about some of
them
in this briefing uh from uh the future
of economic growth
uh in in the world um to
uh addressing uh the uh uh covid
pandemic uh
to uh security issues around the world
so they have a range of topics they can
clearly discuss um and uh certainly it
should be seen as significant that it's
the president's first stop on a foreign
trip
this is his first meeting with the queen
is that something he's always
looked forward to does he have any kind
of relationship with her almost for the
first time who among us wouldn't want to
meet the queen
um i i don't i don't have anything more
personal to read out i i
i will check and see if he has met her
in the past um i believe he has but let
me check on that
uh to confirm for sure they issued of
course a
graceful invitation uh which he
certainly accepted he's looking forward
to
seeing her with dr biden as well on a
couple days into his trip
the president talks about the american
jobs plan and what it does for
closing the racial wealth gap does he
give a cast iron guarantee that whatever
these negotiate negotiations are with
republicans that will remain
intact there will be no compromise on
racial equity
uh racial equity and addressing racial
equity is central to the president's
initiatives his commitments uh
to uh rebuilding our economy around the
country and certainly
he's not going to give up on that i'm
sorry i've got to wrap it up for another
meeting
apologize thanks everyone 1.4
plan because i will allow you to do the
math yourself thank you everyone
you